[Music]
many of us will experience some kind of
trauma during our lifetime
sometimes we escape with no long-term
effects
but for millions of us those experiences
linger
causing symptoms like flashbacks
nightmares and negative thoughts that
interfere with everyday life
this phenomenon called post-traumatic
stress disorder or ptsd
isn't a personal failing rather it's a
treatable malfunction of certain
biological mechanisms that allow us to
cope
with dangerous experiences to understand
ptsd
we first need to understand how the
brain processes a wide range of ordeals
including the death of a loved one
domestic violence
injury or illness abuse rape
war car accidents and natural disasters
these events can bring on feelings of
danger and helplessness
which activate the brain's alarm system
known as the fight
flight freeze response when this alarm
sounds the hypothalamic pituitary and
adrenal systems
known as the hpa axis work together to
send signals to the autonomic
nervous system that's the network that
communicates with adrenal glands and
internal organs to help regulate
functions like heart rate
digestion and respiration these signals
start a chemical cascade
that floods the body with several
different stress hormones
causing physiological changes that
prepare the body to defend itself
our heart rate speeds up breathing
quickens and muscles tense
even after a crisis is over escalated
levels of stress hormones may last for
days
contributing to jittery feelings
nightmares and other symptoms
for most people these experiences
disappear within a few days to two weeks
as their hormone levels stabilize but a
small percentage of those who experience
trauma have persistent problems
sometimes vanishing temporarily only to
resurface
months later we don't completely
understand what's happening in the brain
but one theory is that the stress
hormone cortisol
may be continuously activating the fight
flight freeze response
while reducing overall brain functioning
leading to a number of negative symptoms
these symptoms often fall into four
categories intrusive thoughts
like dreams and flashbacks avoiding
reminders of the trauma
negative thoughts and feelings like fear
anger and guilt
and reactive symptoms like irritability
and difficulty sleeping not everyone has
all these symptoms or experiences them
to the same extent and intensity
when problems last more than a month
ptsd is often diagnosed
genetics ongoing overwhelming stress
and many risk factors like pre-existing
mental illnesses or lack of emotional
support
likely play a role in determining who
will experience ptsd
but the underlying cause is still a
medical
a major challenge of coping with ptsd is
sensitivity to triggers
physical and emotional stimuli that the
brain associates with the original
trauma
these can be everyday sensations that
aren't inherently dangerous
but prompt powerful physical and
emotional reactions
for example the smell of a campfire
could evoke the memory of being trapped
in a burning house for someone with ptsd
that memory activates the same
neurochemical cascade as the original
event
that then stirs up the same feelings of
panic and helplessness
as if they're experiencing the trauma
all over again
trying to avoid these triggers which are
sometimes unpredictable
can lead to isolation that can leave
people feeling invalidated
ignored or misunderstood like a pause
button has been pushed on their lives
while the rest of the world continues
around them
but there are options if you think you
might be suffering from ptsd
the first step is an evaluation with a
mental health professional
who can direct you towards the many
resources available
psychotherapy can be very effective for
ptsd
helping patients better understand their
triggers
and certain medications can make
symptoms more manageable
as can self-care practices like
mindfulness and regular exercise
what if you notice signs of ptsd in a
friend or family member
social support acceptance and empathy
are key to helping and recovery
let them know you believe their account
of what they're experiencing
and that you don't blame them for their
reactions if they're open to it
encourage them to seek evaluation and
treatment
ptsd has been called the hidden wound
because it comes without outward
physical signs
but even if it is an invisible disorder
it doesn't have to be a silent one
mental health conditions impact millions
of people around the world
yet are often misunderstood check out
this playlist to get informed
you